tonight acting DHS secretary Chad Wolfe
is condemning this violence refusing to
stand down he joins us live on the
ground in Portland sir thank you for
being with us I guess the first question
is okay in every case where the
president has offered and given help
Minneapolis DC for example things have
gotten under control
Seattle we had reports and then
confirmed by the president he said yeah
we said we're gonna go in which
precipitated finally the end of the chop
chairs on where innocent people died now
it's happened in other cities you just
see the violence in Chicago you see the
violence in New York other places so now
you're gonna get lectured by a mayor
that is doing nothing to stop the
violence or protect businesses in that
city well thank you for having me Sean
and that's exactly right so earlier this
week I called not only the mayor but the
governor I offer DHS support to help
them locally address the situation
that's going on in Portland and their
only response was please pack up and go
home
and that's just not going to happen on
my watch so we need to make sure that
we're supporting our law enforcement
officers here and making sure that
they're going to continue to protect the
federal courthouse here that's what the
DHS does that's our mission we're not
going to advocate our mission our
responsibilities however whatever the
local leadership here is telling us
we're gonna do our job we're gonna do it
professionally but we're not gonna have
these violent anarchists who show up
about the same time every night for a
series of hours in having that federal
destruction to property I was able to
tour the courthouse here
I saw the graffiti I saw the broken
windows the broken doors there's a
there's a facility right across the
street from the courthouse it has 47
coats of paint on it they have to paint
the facility every night after it gets
graffiti'd so it's time that we take a
stand it's time that the local leaders
here publicly condemned what the violent
anarchists are doing and only then I
think will police local police and
federal police get this under control
I've been saying if you like what's
happening in New York Chicago Seattle
now Portland and other places get
cities run by Liberal Democrats for
decades that would be a preview of
coming attractions if Joe Biden is
elected I'm trying to wrap my mind
around this they you are offering to
help create safety and security for the
people of Portland the president's
offered all of these cities now he can
constitutionally use the 1807
insurrection act but the president has
also said that he is going to go in and
he's going to restore order in these war
zones what will that entail we're gonna
hear apparently very soon absolutely and
again we continue to offer that support
specifically here in Portland wanting to
make sure that they have enough assets
whether its personnel whether its
capabilities and that was my direct ask
an offer to the mayor and again the only
response was was police pack up and go
home and again I you know I asked the
mayor and I asked others what do you
think that's going to occur if that
we're gonna have a courthouse we're
gonna have federal facilities overrun
again by these violent anarchist so what
I'm asking all state and local leaders
here in Portland in Oregon has come out
specifically and publicly condemned
these violent anarchists because
otherwise you're creating an environment
you're fostering an environment that
continues to breed this type of
lawlessness we saw this back in 2018
unfortunately here in Portland where
they set siege to a nice facility for
over twenty eight days so this is the
type of environment again that's foster
here we've had enough of it we're gonna
continue to protect the courthouse and
do our mission at the end of the day all
right secretary wolf it's mind numbing
to me protecting business protecting
citizens safety and security you don't
have safety and security you can't have
life liberty and a pursuit of happiness
it's impossible thank you sir all right